was ist dann Herr März trumpistisch er
macht eine Form er treibt seine seine
Partei in eine politische
Auseinandersetzung rein die er am Ende
nur gewinnen kann wenn er eine Mehrheit
hat für eine Alleinregierung er macht
alle Wege in andere Richtung zu also
wenn man jetzt mal unterstellen würde
man wollle Olaf Scholz davon überzeugen
die Grünen rauszuschmeißen das ja das
was einige cdul fordern die sind ja auch
nicht so n zu uns ne passiert ja auch ja
in der Bundesregierung habe ich das noch
nicht erlebt aber die wollen das in der
Bundesregierung haben und dann möchte
möchte Herr Scholz mit Herrn März
kalieren was Herr März gefallen würde
weil dann wäre die Frage
Kanzlerkandidatur geklärt dann würde ich
das nicht so machen dann würde ich das
etwas eleganter machen und nicht in der
Art und Weise wie er es gemacht hat und
das meine ich mit trumpiskisch
Opposition um jeden Preis egal was dabei
[Musik]
rauskommt